you've written a book uh silver screen
fiend and this is
uh this is a labor of love for you
because i've known this for a while you
are addicted you have a movie addiction
you see almost every movie
well especially during that four-year
period
i saw at one point i saw 262 films
just in the theater that's not kind of
what i watched on tv and dvd 262 movies
that you bought a ticket for and went
and bought a ticket for it went
mainly to a place called the new beverly
where they would show a double feature
every night
uh i saw in four years i saw more than
725 films
yeah it was sad it was almost like like
heroin
i would at least been interacting with
people to go buy it like this was just
me
sitting in the dark and absorbing i just
got stuck in the i
if i absorb enough movies i'll become a
director like in my head that's what i
thought
really oh it was crazy the idea was that
if you saw enough movies i mean it makes
sense if you saw enough you would like
pick up on the skill of filmmaking and
then you could make your own movie in my
head i was like well scorsese saw every
movie ever made and
quentin tarantino watches everything but
then i didn't make the next sleepless
and then when they're done watching
movies they go make them i
got finished watching five movies a day
and the next day i would come and go
i should see five more so you know i
have all
this weird movie now did you see uh
mostly movies that you liked or were
there movies did you see some
questionable you must have seen i mean
if you've seen that many movies you're
seeing some dodgy movies i saw
one movie oh my gosh what was it hang on
was it shark to puss versus terry no i
wish although
i mean that i did okay
as people make fun of like sharknado and
shark to push and stuff like that
there's a movie called deep blue sea and
the whole idea is they're trying to cure
alzheimer's
and in the process of finding the cure
they have to work on mako sharks
and it makes the shark super intelligent
so so what the whole premise of the
movie is
to stop grandma pooping in her pants
when she gets to be 80.
we're gonna fill the sea with near
indestructible genius-level killing
machines
like that's the whole trade-off of that
movie yes which makes it so brilliant
yeah yeah have you ever seen i brought
this up the other day and and andy's
seen it too
and you guys are too young to have seen
this but there was a movie that was only
on television
but i think one of the greatest things
ever called killdozer you ever seen
yeah killdozer there's a bull there's a
bunch of some guys on a deserted on like
an island doing construction
exactly they have a bulldozer and this
is the plot a
a meteor hits the island and for some
reason that they never explain it makes
the bulldozer come to life and want to
destroy
all humans but it's a bulldozer its top
speed is eight miles an hour
but they show guys like ah and they
start to run and they fall
and they lay there for the ten minutes
it takes
for the bulldozer to get to them and my
favorite part is one guy's running away
and the bulldozers all he has to do is
climb a tree
yeah or just go get in the woods that's
all he has to do or get in the driver's
seat of the bulldog
get in the privacy of the bulldozer what
this guy does is he runs on the river
against he runs and he gets in like an
aluminum tube
in front of the bulldozer and hides in
it and it crushes the aluminum tube
you got to see killdozer that's what i'm
here to do i'm just having second
thoughts about my movie where this
meteor comes down and
hits a zamboni
all you have to do is step in the desert
well no i know it's set in jamaica i
don't know what i was
thinking oh my god
all right why did you bring that up i
don't know we should work together
exactly